a shark movie without any bite Meg 2 the
trench isn't making a splash with Rotten
Tomatoes critics for some surprising
reasons in 2018 director John Turtle
Tom's surprised audience says with his
kinetic and intriguing the Meg based on
Steve Alton's novel of the same name the
film follows a Megalodon that passes a
group of scientists and a very exhausted
Jason Statham while it was far from
perfect the Meg was good summer fun
giving viewers a compelling action-heavy
Journey to the depths of the ocean in a
landscape littered with superhero flicks
and reboots the Meg was a breath of
fresh Blockbuster air that featured an
All-Star cast and a competent narrative
about big sharks what else could anyone
want audiences around the world were
receptive to Turtle tob's nightmare with
shark flick helping the Meg gross over
500 million dollars at the global box
office after proving itself as a global
financial success it wasn't surprising
to hear that Warner Brothers was
interested in a sequel Jonas we've got
nothing left almost nothing Ben Wheatley
the author behind free free fire and
kill list was brought on board to helm
the sequel seeing as Wheatley had never
helmed a large big budget Blockbuster
before having the British electricity of
the Meg II the trenched ship felt like
an inspiring decision could Wheatley
turn a potentially bloated sequel into a
genuine pulse-pounding work of deep sea
horror it doesn't look like it wasn't
Tomatoes critics were the first to see
wheatley's Meg II the trench and they're
not very enthusiastic about it IGN
critic Matt Donato was not impressed
with the film at all writing Meg 2 the
trench has all the excitement of fishing
solo for two hours without a single bite
button Tomatoes critics were
surprisingly disappointed with how Meg
II the trench is occupied with elevating
itself instead of fully leaning into its
insane premise Graham took it of stuff
wrote Meg 2 is burdened with an actual
plot the Sharks barely show up and when
they do they are such clearly CGI
Creations it really does look as though
Statham and Chums are being attacked by
characters from an animation that have
stumbled into the wrong film deadline
wasn't impressed with the Sci-Fi aquatic
sequel either saying at several points
along the way you could bang your hand
to your forehead in reaction to how
random and non-transporting the action
is even when there's a great deal of it
this was a bad idea
just a little bit well a movie about
giant sharks certainly won't appeal to
everyone is the film fun at least Cinema
Blends Eric Eisenberg was particularly
disappointed in the film saying make it
to the trench wants to just be seen as
dumb fun but it doesn't turn it clearly
most the critics who took to Rotten
Tomatoes before the film's release
weren't fans of Meg 2. some critics went
ahead and even labeled the film as
boring perhaps the worst assessment any
project can receive but despite the
mediocre reviews Meg 2 the trench still
has some fans in its sunken Corner color
Mart of the New York Times had a few
positive sentiments about the film
saying that the Secor features a spark
of wit that fits in effortlessly with
its narrative Katie Walter the Saint
Louis Post-Dispatch also acknowledged
her film's shortcomings but couldn't
help but come around to wheatley's
chaotic Vision as it rubbed up writing
about halfway through Meg to the trench
this self-serious sequel suddenly
becomes funny leaning into the slippery
silliness of a summer shark flick Liz
Shannon Miller of consequence put it
bluntly reminding viewers that this is
Osman a movie about giant sharks saying
Meg to the trench is a far more coherent
entry in the genre than others with
effects work that's several notches
Above the Rest well most Rotten Tomatoes
critics are sour on the Meg sequel there
are a few that find the film compelling
enough well these mixed to negative
reviews impact the film's box office
only time will tell
foreign